[Musica]
Ciao a tutti
Ciao Bergamo
[Musica]
Ciao a tutti Io adesso faccio arrabbiare
il mio coach voglio iniziare voglio
prendere proprio qualche secondo per
farvi i complimenti come comunità
bergamasca perché
tirare in piedi una roba del genere non
è non è scontato e vorrei che fosse poco
retorico questo complimento iniziale mi
ha ricordato un po' gli Stati Uniti dove
è molto acceso il concetto di comunità
in Italia Noi abbiamo siamo un po' più
attenti alla famiglia no ci preoccupiamo
per la mamma il fratello la nonna Forse
il vicino di casa però diciamo che la
comunità invece a Bergamo questa cosa la
senti L'abbiamo sentita con la pandemia
e la sentiamo con questo Ted volevo fare
i complimenti quindi a Giorgio alonni e
a tutti sono
tantissimi volontari che hanno reso
questa cosa possibile perché a Bergamo
c'è un senso di comunità quando sono
cadute le torri gemelle vi ricordate che
arrivavano tutti da tutta l'America per
aiutare a tirare via i detriti
Probabilmente erano di Bergamo Mi vien
da dire allora
io mi occupo di arte e faccio il
giornalista e nel mio settore
voi non servite a niente
il pubblico in generale è superfluo
mettiamola così perché Perché
le arti visive erano una cosa Popolare
fino alla fine dell'Ottocento poi pian
pianino sono diventate un discorso
delitto un discorso un po' esclusivo
l'arte contemporanea tende a essere
esclusiva
nell'accezione più brutto del termine
Nel senso che esclude lo spettatore Ma
questo ve lo motivo non è un'impressione
la Biennale di Venezia che è la
manifestazione più importante dedicata
all'arte del mondo direi l'anno fondata
nel
1895 e già nei primi anni del Novecento
faceva mezzo milione di visitatori non
eravamo 8 miliardi ci si andava in nave
o a cavallo
quest'anno è in corso l'abbiamo di
Venezia vi consiglio di andarlo a vedere
perché è una manifestazione importante
dura fino a novembre e
faranno 600 mila visitatori lo stesso
numero Solo che siamo 8 miliardi di
persone e abbiamo il treno
perché non gli interessa più di tanto
perché è complicata perché perché l'arte
contemporanea non si capisce in un certo
modo no c'è un bellissimo film del 1972
con Alberto Sordi che si chiamava Le
vacanze intelligenti Alberto Sordi fa il
fruttarolo Romano il fruttivendolo e ai
figli che si laureano e e vogliono che i
genitori che non hanno studiato vadano a
fare delle vacanze culturali li mandano
la Biennale di Venezia ma è la Biennale
di Venezia quella vera
non è ricostruita era la Biennale del
1972 curata da razziman uno dei più
grandi curatori e critici d'arte del
Novecento di Alberto Sordi non capisce
niente e neanche la moglie la moglie
stanca in questo pomeriggio agostano a
un certo punto si siede di fianco a una
palma e viene scambiata per un'opera
d'arte
questo non è che succede solo ad Alberto
Sordi succede a tutti a me tante volte è
capitato di dover chiedere se gli
occhiali per terra fossero un'opera o
degli occhiali per terra perché l'arte
contemporanea Insomma è cambiata duchamp
in avanti sono successe tantissime cose
nel Novecento però insomma diciamo è
rimasto un circolo chiuso ed esclusivo
un circolo ricchissimo Eh perché tutti
gli scambi nel mondo annuali fanno un
volume di circa 67 70 miliardi di
dollari
sono tanti soldi perché è anche un modo
per investire denaro no c'è chi compra
la casa ma si possono comprare anche i
quadri i quadri nel tempo La pittura fa
il 75% di tutto questo volume quindi noi
andiamo avanti ma diciamo poi con la
tecnologia il digitale le cose diciamo
il volume grosso lo fa ancora la pittura
e ci sono una serie di protagonisti in
questo mondo ci sono delle case d'asta
ci sono delle gallerie d'arte ci sono
degli Artisti perché dicevo che voi non
servite a niente perché ha un artista di
arte contemporanea
a differenza delle altre Industrie
culturali non gli interessa più di tanto
gli interessa avere una buona galleria
un paio di collezionisti e lui vive e se
la cava
nelle altre Industrie culturali il
pubblico è fondamentale perché se io
faccio il musicista e al mio concerto
non ci viene nessuno Voi capite se
scrivo un libro e nessuno mi compra il
libro Quindi il pubblico è fondamentale
se al cinema non ci vai a vedere il film
e
poi però
a un certo punto arriva il digitale
arriva il digitale e cambia tutto il
digitale ha cambiato le nostre vite Le
sta cambiando le ha già cambiate e le
cambierà in una maniera irreversibile
è arrivato prima in tutte le altre
Industrie culturali non so se qualcuno
si ricorda Napster nel 1999 era una
piattaforma di Peer to peer dove potevi
scaricare delle canzoni che qualcun
altro aveva uplodato i Metallica fecero
causa Napster e poi insomma sappiamo un
po' com'è andata a finire c'è questa è
una domanda che mi interessa c'è
qualcuno di voi che quest'anno ha
comprato un CD
hai 95 anni probabilmente
Diciamo che non è Sto scherzando
ovviamente sarà persone importantissime
io io non ho più neanche il lettore no
del cd a casa e perché Perché quando
arriva il digitale il digitale se non
governato distrugge valore e non lo crea
però di sicuro non si torna indietro Sì
c'è la moda del vinile Ma è una micro
nicchia questa cosa è successa in tutte
le altre Industrie è successo
nell'editoria
giornali non li vendiamo più
è successo con i libri che però sono
quelli che hanno resistito un po' di più
No perché la carta piace ancora e è
successo con sta succedendo anche adesso
con il cinema No
nelle arti visive il digitale non c'era
non Sì qualche case d'asta qualche casa
d'asta vendeva online le cose ma insomma
poca roba e poi c'è una data come prima
e dopo Cristo che è il marzo 2021
in cui uno sconosciuto americano
si chiama bipol Non so se qualcuno di
voi ha sentito questo nome People
all'anagrafe è Mike winkelmann Un
Illustrissimo sconosciuto vende un'opera
d'arte
in un'asta pubblica A 69 milioni di
dollari e diventa in quel giorno il
terzo artista vivente più pagato al
mondo
e questo qui non aveva mai venduto
niente prima un'opera d'arte digitale
era la raccolta lui fa Faceva dei
disegni delle vignette satiriche alcune
molto divertenti ce n'è una di elon musk
muscoloso in mutande dove prende sempre
un po' in giro fa satira e ha fatto ogni
giorno per 5.000 giorni un'immagine ho
fatto un grande collage e l'ha venduto a
questa cifra astronomica Ma come come
mai direte voi cioè perché l'arte
digitale l'arte col computer si è
iniziati a farla negli anni 60 si
chiamava netta Art è stato possibile
perché è arrivata una tecnologia che
consente di
scambiare e vendere dei file i file in
informatica li abbiamo inventati per
poter essere copiati se no non avremmo
avuto i computer Sono uguali uno
all'altro
è arrivata questa tecnologia degli nft
qualcuno l'ha mai l'avrete sentito da
qualche parte nft non fungible token
sono dei certificati di
provenienza e proprietà e
che vengono registrati sulla blockchain
Ora io ho poco tempo e non voglio fare
una lezione di informatica qua però
è fondamentale questo strumento perché
ha reso in qualche maniera il file unico
questi certificati dicono che Giacomo è
proprietario di qualcosa dell'opera di
biple e lo dicono sulla blockchain
quindi un grande archivio condiviso
Quindi tutti in tutto il mondo di
centralizzato sanno che io sono
proprietario di quel file di quell'opera
d'arte
e questo fa tutta la differenza del
mondo perché rende questi oggetti che
prima non lo erano collezionabili
perché ci sono sempre stati gli artisti
digitali quelli che facevano ma non li
consideravamo artisti li consideravamo
delle maestranze dei grafici e dei nonni
creativi e adesso sono artisti
e cambia tutto ma non cambia tutto
Soltanto perché si muovono dei volumi di
soldi ma cambia
è rivoluzionario proprio per il per come
è impostato il sistema dell'arte perché
il sistema dell'Arte è sempre stato
piramidale e invece adesso con il
digitale partiamo dal basso perché
questi signori come fanno a vendere a
così tanti soldi perché se sono
costruiti delle comunità su internet
delle Community Che Li sostengono e poi
eventualmente decidono anche di
comperare le loro cose e
quindi diventa Democratico diventa di
nuovo un qualcosa che tu puoi andare a
vedere e se ti piace condividere o
sostenere lo comprendi non ti non ti
allontana
diventa come nelle altre Industrie
culturali Voi capite Di che razza di
rivoluzione stiamo parlando è un
qualcosa che cambierà completamente il
mondo dell'arte nei prossimi negli anni
a venire
e se ci pensiamo e quanto di più
naturale poteva succedere
Io credo che se Michelangelo Oggi
rinascesse sono stato a Firenze qualche
giorno fa perché c'era la Biennale
dell'antiquariato una manifestazione
bellissima
se Michelangelo rinascesse Secondo voi
andrebbe a Carrara nella cava
dell'altissimo staccarsi un blocco di
marmo di queste dimensioni A parte che
sta finendo il marmo ma non io non credo
io credo che Michelangelo andrebbe al
centro commerciale a comperarsi un
computer e probabilmente farebbe arte
con il computer perché la materia del
nostro tempo di sicuro non è l'acrilico
Di sicuro non è l'olio di sicuro non è
il bronzo e di sicuro non è il marmo la
materia del nostro tempo non c'è è
l'immateriale è il software è il
digitale
e questo
non deve farci paura non deve essere un
downgrade qualitativo è un upgrade
qualitativo perché noi possiamo fare
quello che vogliamo con gli strumenti
digitali abbiamo
miliardi di colori io non so se qualcuno
di voi ha fatto l'artistico le scuole lo
sapete la difficoltà che c'è per fare un
colore no per un pittore è sempre stato
il cruccio fondamentale intanto farlo
perché non è che lo tiri fuori dal
tubetto e lo usi così rosso vado No cioè
insomma c'è uno studio e poi farlo
rimanere attaccato uno dei grandissimi
problemi di Leonardo Da Vinci era
mantenere permanente quella pittura
soprattutto con l'affresco
il digitale cambia tutto però ci
costringe a
evolvere e ad aggiornarci regolarmente
il ciclo di innovazione ha superato il
ciclo di vita
Cosa vuol dire vuol dire che mio nonno
andava all'università si laureava e bene
o male Faceva quel lavoro lì tutta la
vita perché aveva imparato a fare
qualcosa lo poteva fare fino fino alla
pensione Non succede più col digitale lo
dico soprattutto ai giovani mettetevelo
in testa bisogna fare l'università tutti
gli anni perché cambia tutto di anno in
anno
questa cosa non la si può fermare il
digitale non si ferma il digitale va
assecondato va compreso
bisogna usare le due parole che si usano
per il cambiamento climatico mitigazione
e adattamento bisogna adattarsi a questa
cosa e coglierne le opportunità e Sono
bellissime le opportunità Credetemi Ho
un'amica che ha fondato un museo di arte
esclusivamente digitale si chiama mogda
è online è solo online e
raccoglie le opere d'arte di artisti da
tutto il mondo
alcuni non hanno gli occhi per piangere
vengono da Paesi poverissimi le mandano
delle cose che hanno fatto ho visto
un'opera d'arte di un ragazzo argentino
che era fatta tutta solo in World ha
fatto un lavoro talmente complicato che
neanche quello che ha inventato World
riusciva a farlo
Io non lo so come ha fatto quello lì ma
ce l'ha fatta
è un mondo nuovo
e però cosa ci serve Ci serve
cultura
Parliamo tantissimo di digitalizzazione
a sproposito dalla mattina alla sera
parliamo di metaversi non sappiamo
neanche cosa sono dobbiamo formarci però
Angela che ci ha lasciato qualche
settimana fa diceva ha detto una frase
bellissima che è la cultura è quello che
ti rimane quando hai dimenticato tutto
quello che hai studiato
e a noi ci serve proprio quella roba lì
ci serve renderci conto che questo
oggetto non è uno strumento che
adoperiamo per telefonare qua dentro
questo non è qualcosa di altro dalla
nostra vita A me fa sorridere quando
dicono Vabbè ma tutto virtuale virtuale
cosa Ragazzi qua dentro ci sono ci sono
i miei soldi ci sono i miei desideri le
aziende di marketing sanno esattamente
cosa voglio comperare Che tipo di
cliente possa essere ci sono i miei
sentimenti ci sono i miei segreti
c'è tutto quando io perdo questo
strumento perdo molto più che un affare
per telefonare quindi è molto reale è
molto più reale Questo non è il futuro
Questo è oggi Adesso c'è anche l'arte
anche l'arte ha scoperto
che ci sono nuove
fantastiche possibilità
Creative e ci sono nuove fantastiche
possibilità anche per fruirla dall'altra
parte del mondo istantaneamente
arriveranno dei display
adatti dei device adatti degli Oculus
delle arriveranno un sacco di cose
dovremmo avere la cultura sufficiente
per non perderci per strada questo
cambiamento e per assecondarlo e io dico
che la cosa bella
e che
il pubblico nel mondo dell'Arte è
tornato protagonista Quindi voi adesso
Potete tornare a casa andare su alcuni
di questi Portali
Come andare come come quando si va al
museo
e quindi io vi dico di tornare a casa e
dare una carezza al vostro telefonino
Ciao a tutti
[Applauso]